maîtriser le sujet proposé une petite
question
qui collait le roma le lama ceux qui
savent le homard
ok je n'ai déjà exigé que l'offre je
parle des hommages ne parle pas de
l'acteur s'est pas au hamas on a déjà
percé dans le coma l'animal
au gaz et qu'ils connaissent j'aimerais
poursuivre
qui sait convaincre a dit l'oms a
relevé la mère toujours et abondamment
alors le romain est un bon lustres
ministre
qui vit dans une carapace à rigide qui
est le grand dit jamais alors on arrive
à se demander mais du coup qu'on va
faire le roumain pour gagner
c'est tout simple
alger deux niveaux la croissance
le roman devient un contretemps dans sa
carapace
il est stressé il est sous pression
alors qui finit par se rendre sous les
rochers et qui se chevauchent et se
protéger des prédateurs il finit par se
rangent les rochers pour se débarrasser
de certains à bazas et à fabriquer
nouvelle
est bien évident à mile island joue
d'audace ou cette nouvelle carapace tu
as également tout petit il empêcha de
croître alors le cycle va se répéter
ainsi je suis tout au long de sa vie
la nar à la base c'est à protéger leur
langue sa fonction mail à gijon là où
cette carapace se oublier devient une
prison et tout le connard
gérard pussey car et cela en tête quand
nos alliés réunis
quant aux charges ambitieux comme l'a si
bien dit c'est trop gros car la jalle
dominique et corrigé l'information qui
suit nous water par accident mais leurs
estimations
j'aime ce soit vous a marqué avec moi
pour un voyage à travers le temps et
l'espace ne vous en faites pas pour ce
voyage vous n'aurez besoin une idée
izany même de passeports à part loin et
de vaccins anti corps là juste à me
donner votre attention et le suivre
pendant une quinzaine de minutes
nous évoluons en 2010
je suis un jeune garçon
introverti qui peut justement
le confort de sa petite zone de confort
a justement la réalité je passe le temps
à l'idée documents des livres souvent
dérive depuis 2000 pages que j'ai des
voix en moins d'une semaine à 13 ans je
connais beaucoup de choses
je connais des choses de ce monde et
surtout je sais comment naissent les
étoiles que ces premières loges ou
poneys les kwasa l'alcoolisme soulevait
alexandre le grand notamment je sais
même qu'elle est l'unique l'allié de
détruire l'anneau de son rang
ces indications sérieuses ait
même pas ce qu'il fait chaque jour c'est
justement qu'on va avoir les
interactions sociales comment
communiquer avec mes gamins qu'on va pas
intéresser plus j'apprends avec les
autres cela se limite pour moi et c'est
ainsi que je poursuis peu à peu
justement mon bout de chemin juste a
ordonné un bac à 2013 avec le diplôme
vient questionner à quoi cela sert-il
d'accueillir autant de connaissances si
je ne partage pas avec déjà je ne suis
pas en mesure de rouvrir ou d'argueil
reçu le monde pourrait s'ouvrir à moi
il fallait le chargent alors j'ai décidé
de changer il ne connaît pas vrai ce
changement
ç'a aidé d'apprendre islam ex la pluie
alors j'ai décidé de m'inscrire à la
liturgie de l'église et un suivants
commerce de l'édition rage parce que je
n'étais pas du tout doux et surprise
chavez je n'étais pas du tout
mais tôt ou tard il a eu le jour où il
faut laisser la vie pétition est allé en
action c'est la colère j'empoche dernier
à l'église et là il y avait des stars de
youtube qui me real est bizarre un peu
comme ce soir si jamais peur
ce jour là j'ai appris des fonctions de
mon coach ignorait tout en l'herm mes
pieds les mains mais lève la voix
les dépêches
mais j'étais là quelques jours je me
suis dit marc et de la lèze qu'il faut
que tu y ailles
alors tant bien que mal j'ai fait la
lecture jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas fait
tout ce que j'ai fait exactement je
pense peu à quelque part on s'est voulu
protéger en effaçant les détails et à la
fin j'étais
je ne sentais pas bien je me disais
j'avais tout gagné les gens de l'endroit
messi puis lorsque je sors
je pense pas la recette mais surprise
lorsque je sors je suis un posté par un
tube avec un la suie qui ma belle aux
petits vient hélas jeu multi peut-être
que j'ai été produit avec la main ça n'a
pas très incités x16 j'ai des fans et là
il marque je me dis c'est d'être
qu'apple allait q je dis oui je veux dit
félicitations vraiment rare pour la
performance que tu as fait
finalement c'était pas si mal
je la fais hélas il comme tu me le dis
franchement c'est super et noix les
jeunes aujourd'hui qui s'engagent de jeu
pour l'église c'est bien de faire la
lecture ap le sial si la crau al il y a
les enfants de choeur qui a les éléments
de baisse entre castermant de balayer le
servi à l'église finalement jeudi la
lecture c'est assez obligé voiture
d'échangés
malienne est gentille et polie que me
dit que j'avais été et c'est canal que
j'ai massacré la lecture ça n'allait pas
du tout aujourd'hui ch paris avec pour
mais à l'époque je vous assure que
c'est dur dieu police belge a levé parce
que le pire dans tout ça c'est que dans
le regard de soutien tu vois de la
sincérité
ils parlent pas après tout brésil le dit
pas ou très mal
c'est vrai et offrant tu le sais
et c'est là que j'apprends que les
aigles tutoie les sommets les escargots
aussi sauf qu'ils ont marre
et supplices moyeu du ballet de
l'histoire alors j'allais baby j'en ai
marre et j'ai dit je n'arrête pas la
masse que lorsqu'on est au fond du tout
au fond il n'y a qu'une seule direction
il faut qu'un pays commandez on peut pas
tomber encore plus bas alors j'ai visé
de conduire j'ai fait des répétitions
j'ai lu c'est toujours terrible mais
plus j'utilise et mieux je le savais
j'avais plus brutale peur je
m'améliorais et on vous donne rendez
même degré assez bon tant et si bien
qu'on ne contient les plus jeunes pour
que gta iv
lorsqu'on veut vraiment
et lorsqu'on 6è au fini par faire le
lien possible et c'est cela justement
qui nous amène à notre première escale
nous sommes en 2015
et c'était les dix ans d'université
cette occasion il y avait pléthore
d'objets d'activités organisées et avec
les charges la de football soit diverses
a également anna est une compétition a
retenu mon attention
un petit celui d'emma oratoire venir
prix sans me fassih fin je pense qu'à
l'époque j'avais jamais te laisser en
friche à la mémoire
des balkans je ne savais pas trop ce que
c'était mais en tant que les conneries
gestionnaire de formation sans les frais
sans je connais très bien et c'était une
dimension puisque suffisent à vous que
je partage alors j'ai fait rapidement
une petite équipe et on y va pour les
matchs surprise
victoire écrasante victoire
pas de mon équipe que l'équipe en face à
mende ans s'est fait massacrer
on s'est fait passer le jour là j'ai
perdu lancera le match
l'espoir des sabres ifa mais également 2
3 de la trinité mais paradoxalement cela
c'est à la finale de cette même
compétition
même si j'étais par compétiteur marché
des browsers spectateurs je pense que
j'ai été heureux gagnants
parce que ça explique à gagny la
reporter trouvé laissant le gisement se
joue là à voir des choses comme les
camarades à ma faible portant de
sagacité dans leur éloquence va lever
pouvoir convaincre steve la foule de
cette manière chiffrée
et là je vois le nid j'ai eu un réel
intérêt taking plagiat mais je tiens à
préciser que martin luther king n'ayant
pas le rôle du sommeil mais pas avant le
congrès dont jeudi chez lui un rêve le
rêve un jour quelqu'un prendre ces gens
là le rêve d'ajouter en 48 heures alors
juste après cette compétition j'ai
commencé
c'est moi lorsque j'avais 13 ans et s'il
ya un doute c'est moi qui porte le
consultant pièce désolé de mon père que
je suis est le nez
comme en défense ils m'ont dit que
j'étais simple le jour là
donc je commence justement à malgré les
et pelé année sera l'année 3ème année
beaucoup de compétition mais
malheureusement à chaque fois
je ne l'aï jamais à emporter le titre
c'était utile que deux victoires deux
matchs mais jamais de paille et pourtant
je mettais à améliorer parce que l'on
peut pas laisser médiocre pendant trois
ans et en plus je m'étais entouré des
meilleurs en tout cas à l'époque
qu'avait fabius il y avait matière et
avec jonathan jonathan est injustement
celui qui a remporté la compétition en
celui qui a inspiré et qui magistrat de
l'avis de l'instance gigawatts des
filaments l'été dans la bible qui est un
peu tout ce qu'ils avaient déjà étoffé
sauf moi et dont ils ont fini par
m'appeler le roi sans couronne
je ne croise un visage que c'était
affectueux
et c'est d'autant plus difficile que à
la raison
maman n'était pas vraiment pour le fait
que je me lance dans les débats watts
parce que robert était
ils disent l'action qui m'éloigne de
l'essentiel les études et à chaque fois
que finalement je finissais par perdre
et que je rentre à la maison tout lisse
elle finissait par le sorti une de ses
phrases fétiches
tu vois
on les enfants l'avocat leur n'écoutez
pas de lui l'animateur du débat aura pas
pu aller au charbon des mois la maison
faut construire seulement car tu peux
non kerry
et c'est là que j'attends que l'os 3
décide enfin de suivre le chemin de ses
rêves bien souvent les plus grands
championnats c'est les personnes qui
nous aident plus les personnels de
posture et ces personnes ne le font pas
par les charges d elles ne font pas en
fait pour vous fait mal bien le progrès
c'est parce qu'elle faisait un peu de
vous protéger et bien ce soir on
protéger ces vies brisées vos rêves car
elles sont en jeu du moins c'est l'ogre
9e et qu'à cette situation se présente
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire je ne sais
pas tout ce que je leur dise que qu'est
ce que moi j'ai décidé de faire et je ne
suis pas allé et j'ai décidé de
continuer et nous arrive à l'escale nous
sommes en 2018 c'est précisément en
octobre 2018 je renvoie par premier home
edition de débats watwan chapelât
nationale de débats world toute façon
avec mon île restée jusqu'à présent
lorsque je ne le cache pas c'est le
titre d'un jeu le précieux se bat là
après cela rien ne dit
cependant après cela ça laisse du vide
une dizaine même titre qu'une foire
nationale ou internationale en tant que
roi tinqueux débatteurs ou encore dans
le coaching tout commençait à aller ça
commence à le récit
et même que
les limiter mais hier soir c'était lui
qui demain
et tant et si bien que finalement la
balle qui faisaient tout premier tissu
aller et là fini par être la présidente
de l'oph en plus
c'était ma coach lorsque je l'aï vu
quand on s'assied et venise et sa femme
nos salades aux oui c'est ça c'est la
bonne voie m.le coûte cher maison et
donc notre décide à brasc de la sa
passion est content pour les cercles de
la voix pendant trois ans pour
ceux qui s'y opposaient
longtemps les encarts logis pas ce que
c'est ils ont que peu importe ce qu'ils
vont faire nous allons y aller à rome
autant de soutenir
donc il faut la persévérance et après on
rassure nos proches qui ne pourront
ensuite nous accompagnent
et c'est ainsi que nous arrivons
troisième escale 2020 ou en deux
pénalités en 2018
2020 après kobe congé maladie
et l'âge le soin visage
de la petite halle aux grains de monex
de ma copine de l'époque qui est mon ex
aujourd'hui et cela disait dominique
pinon et jacques adamo l'italie
t'appelles pas compris la du sérieux
c'est pas beau de dijon était donc de
mary aiguë
tu ne sais pas communiquer il dit quoi
deux minutes il sait pas communiquer
challenge que j'ai remporté le
championnat national et du vin oiv roy
gérard brondy l'elysée note au fait tu
me dis que je ne sais pas communiqué
ils vous seront ce que j'ai fait je les
envoie une photo une photo où j'étais
seul devant plus de 500 personnes
et j'étais l'âge de la terre
avec la foule parce que j'ai ce un
communiqué j'ai travaillé ça et là et
voteront en fait je ne comprends pas tu
sais bien paris c'est vrai que tu parles
tu ne sais pas communiqué
les a sûrement que avec le recul je me
rends compte qu'elle a vraiment raison
celle à chaque fois je voulais qu'on
communique lorsque on avait eu dispute
lorsqu'éric et ce qui n'allait pas mais
à chaque fois que je l'appelais beaucoup
à discuter c'est pour pouvoir avoir
raison et chaque fois que j'ai vu des
déboires le pont et je finis toujours
par avoir raison parce que je suis et
les techniques débat oratoire mais la
vie ce n'est pas un match ce n'est pas
une compétition
et c'est un vrai
pendant leur rêve du jeune garçon de 13
ans c'était d'apprendre à partager avec
les gens d'avoir des interactions
sociales de savoir couric et ces départs
et entre animateurs et d'autres qui la
longe dépérissent le chemin alors j'ai
décidé de retravailler cela
et c'est ainsi que je le rends compte
que
finalement ne sont pas si différents des
droits
quand les relations de la soirée
le cousin de l'homme ce n'est pas de
changer c'est le moment
vous pouvez dire que c'est dominique
laudien cru
c'est que nous n'avons pas le cas parce
que physiquement mais reprenons décidant
de suivre nos rêves
nous nommons à l'emprunt d'appel que
nous sommes limités par notre zone de
confort constitué et a priori constituer
deux provinces social de normes de toute
façon je dis pas qu'à part dans ce n'est
pas la peine d'essayer de de façon
d'être je me terrifie ya tant de choses
que nous utilisons pour une zone de vent
fort qui sa part à la can face au dollar
mais lorsqu'on décide dessus le chemin
de nos rêves qui en impose une limite
ils nous ont obligés nous a débarrassés
pour pouvoir grandi
mais c'est difficile quand comme le
volant lancement ce qui va nous être car
a basculé en vo on regarde déjà et le
regard des gens se massent être un
toulouse
mais pourtant nous avons tous déjà fait
josé-luis à repenser à vous voir vous
avez réussi cela a fait quelque chose
dont vous êtes très fier si vous y
passez rien là vous allez vous rendre
compte que juste avant vous étiez
peut-être ce pc sous pression vous avez
réussi à percer bien et tout au long de
leur vie nous sommes pour le moment
aucun qui soit elle repoussera les
limites et finalement les enfants du
multi séculaire sont limitées il s'est
ainsi que j'aimerais qu'on oublie c'est
tout ce qu'on lui et s'il vous plaît
avec moi c'est vous lever et aurait un
exercice on va s'étirer série principale
ça va mal on n'a pas l'air si on va se
tirer ensemble en suivant mouvement
septier
yvonne ouvre les mains
félicitations vous êtes débarrassé de
ouattara passe vous êtes désormais
illimité
[Musique]